[Music]  I'm your biggest fan  oh it's just the most amazing thing  surprise Ellen Page and Emma partner are  officially married the couple revealed  the good news on Instagram Wednesday  posting this photo of their shiny new  wedding bands their captions equally  adorable gushing over how excited they  are to call one another white et spoke  with Paige and partner in October just  two months after they released this  emotional video dancing together plans  to collaborate again she doesn't know  she makes it look like I can dance about  yeah we'll probably do another dance  film in the recent future and maybe  write a film together  what about plans to wrangle her into  acting yeah I mean you can tell by our  videos that she's a great actor so  [Music]